autre annonce de jean castex si hier la
prolongation de la fermeture des salles
de sport jusqu'à la mi-février au moins
pour les professionnels du secteur la
tante prend des allures de traversée du
désert
même s'ils n'ont pas totalement renoncé
vous allez le voir à donner des cours à
tour
le reportage de romain delville et
audrey champigny le midi c'est cyril qui
coachent le cours collectifs au studio
sport face à lui un écran d'ordinateur
avec ses élèves qui font les exercices
en direct à la maison c'est un service
minimum et même s'il y a
s'il ya moins de gens qui se sentent
concernés c'est quand même super sympa
de se voir de ceux de se faire des
coucous et puis de bouger un peu comme
on peut et oui c'est pas pratique mais
au moins au moins pendant 30 minutes on
se connecte avec eux puis à la fin on a
tous le sourire on fait on fait une
petite photo du groupe et c'est ça qui
est sympa quoi le club compte environ
350 adhérents qui cotisent autour de 40
euros par mois en temps normal les
départs sont compensés par l'arrivée de
nouveaux membres
avant la nouvelle fermeture
administrative le protocole sanitaire
était déjà drastique 5 mètres carrés par
personne
le masque dans les zones de circulation
on est prêt à aller encore un peu plus
loin et c'est vrai qu'on tous mes
membres s'occupent de leur santé ils
investissent de l'argent de leur temps
pour bouger pour être bien et j'ai des
gens qui ont des travail un peu
oppressant et qui fin des travaux à peu
près sans pardon et qui finalement n'ont
pas cette petite soupapes et ils
comprennent pas dit auch coach sportif à
domicile a dû investir en informatique
pour assurer des cours en ligne
c'est loin de son credo qui est de faire
du sport avec le mobilier urbain les
agrée pas d'essai qui sont habitués à
couvrir l'extérieur c'est que ceux qui
aiment qui sont dehors papa papa papa
temps n'est pas plaisir à cause de
l'environnement
ceux là je les ai perdus pas tous mais
je n'ai pas dit non le rêve le reste et
savent qu'ils ont confiance et savent
que qu'ils soient en ligne ou pas le
corps a changé
la france veut instaurer sans aucune
visibilité quant à l'avenir de leur
activité
ces professionnels du sport sont dépités
et ce ne sont pas les mesures
gouvernementales annoncées hier qui
pourrait les rassurer